to some encouraging news this noon hour  on the vaccine front drug maker pfizer  says final results show its vaccine is  safe  and 95 effective the u.s reported over  1700 deaths yesterday from coba 19  that is the highest single day total  since may dr  anthony fauci has voiced concerns he  says each state  having different rules will complicate  the response to the current spike in  cases  and the eventual distribution of  vaccines  we need some fundamental public health  measures  that everyone should be adhering to  the first at-home rapid test has now  been given approval by the fda  you do need a prescription for it from a  doctor it gives you results in about  30 minutes that's an at home test